see it on your Friday morning what's
cool at school how about the return of
the Mojave Max desert tortoise education
program Elementary School assemblies
hi it's Mojave Max here with oh hi Max
the partnership between Clark County and
this desert conservation program The
Springs Preserve the school district and
get Outdoors Nevada kicked off this
year's round of school visits with eager
first graders at cozine Elementary from
listening closely as Mr Adam talked
about how tortoises survive in the
desert we share to giggling as Mr Meza
volunteered to be transformed into a
tortoise we hope we gave the kids enough
information to make good educated
guesses about when the real Mojave Max
will wake up from his annual long
winter's nap at the Springs Preserve
because if all of us respect protect and
enjoy our desert together we can say
[Music]
all right Max get down become funky all
elementary students in Clark County can
enter the Mojave Max emergence contest
everything you know at Max's website
prizes they include laptops for the
winning student and their teacher as
well as a field trip to the Springs
Preserve for a pizza party a meet and
greet with the Superstar tortoise the
link on our website we always want to
know what's cool at school if you got
something let us know cool it's cool
under the Community tab on our website
or just email coolatschool at
8newsnow.com and Mojave Max is about as
cool as it gets so I'm thinking he
spends all that time in brumation right
roommating that's when he's writing his
his songs that we just heard
little had those lyrics yeah
oh you gotta do the head Bottle too oh
now the tortoise we got to get him to
add some of your flute in there it's
like a little solo yeah it could be like
a sidebar I'll talk to some people who
know some people